all righty happy thursday y'all
uh thanks for joining me today
um we're just getting started it's right at uh
am central standard time for me here in texas
but we'll wait a few minutes to let some folks
roll in and then we'll get started on the uh
our studio team eval demo we're going to have
a bit of a live code a little bit of slides
and definitely be taking questions as they come up
in the chat if you do have any questions uh feel
free to drop them into the uh youtube uh chat
here um on the live stream that you're watching
so thanks for joining me and again
we'll get started in a little bit
i'm going to go ahead and drop a few links um
into the chat so if you wanted to follow along
or wanted to get more information you could do
so give me one second i'll drop those for you
a lot of the examples i'm using
you can find the public source code
here on my github so that's going to have
some of the details for the slides as well
as some of the example applications
we're showing and are in python
i also have my colleagues from our studio who
will be answering some questions so if you see me
talking and you see people answering questions
in the chat i'm lucky enough to have some some
great team members behind me um we also have kelly
o'brien who's the pack or the our studio connect
um product manager uh so she might answer some
additional questions there in the chat um what
we've been doing is kind of for a lot of these is
if you'd like to say hello in the chat feel free
to say hi to each other in the chat usually it's
between you know 60 and 600 people somewhere in
that range in the group so feel free to talk
amongst yourselves or ask questions as well
and let me go ahead and we're about two
minutes past i'm going to go ahead and
uh start screen shooting here in
a second i saw somebody mention
that there's some echoing so i'm just
checking on that but i think we're okay
all right so let me go ahead and kick this off
and we'll get started so i'm going to share my
whole desktop here um so for today again like i
mentioned there's going to be a little bit of some
slide craft in terms of like we we go some slides
we're going to walk through but the bulk of today
is going to be walking through the rstudio team
evaluation so the team evaluation is all three
of our professional products so rstudio workbench
our studio connect and our studio package manager
the evaluation means that they're time gated in
terms of it it's just trying out the products
and we provide the hosted environment for
that if you did want to try it out you just
fill out this form and you can click start in
the evaluation and then i'll walk through what
the evaluation actually looks like how you can
use the products and then really what today is
about is understanding how these things
fit into your workflow in an enterprise
as well as how do you make some of these arguments
for using open source even if you're not using our
professional products we'd love for you to use
them but even if you're not going to use them
how do you you know motivate
folks to use r and python and
all the wonderful packages that you use
in both languages within your organization
so again i'll jump back into the slides we'll talk
a little bit about our studio team and then we'll
hop over into the evaluation proper and have quite
a bit of live code and kind of walking through the
whole process again for our studio team we think
of this as really like a single home for r and
python for all data science teams so regardless of
your 90 r 10 python or 100 python and no r or some
other mix in the middle we've tried to build these
products in a way that they're serving both kind
of constituencies that both people are very happy
and able to be productive with these products
if you did want to follow along with the
slides you can do this so here i'm going
to drop this link in the chat as well those are
going to be available at colorado.orgstudio.com
rsc rstudio dash team dash prez so again
we're hosting these on our studio connect
so kind of a good fun example there
as far as the three products if you
weren't familiar with them and kind of the
different people who would be interested
you know maybe you're a data scientist or
data analyst maybe you're a decision maker
a business user or someone else kind of trying
to make decisions with data with data science
or maybe you're even uh an r admin or python
admin or an i.t admin that's more concerned about
all this open source work that's being done and
people are trying to be productive but you're
trying to support them and make things secure
and scalable and have proper operations around it
so again we kind of think of this as these are
the three core personas that we're trying to solve
problems for in terms of data scientists really
want to use are in python they want to develop
their applications and share them with their the
rest of the organization whether that's for other
data scientists or for business users trying to
make decisions with the data science work they're
doing and then the it team whether you're an r
admin meaning that you're kind of in both worlds
or a python admin or a traditional it admin you're
just trying to support all this and make things
operate smoothly again the three products are
studio workbench our studio package manager
in our studio connect our studio workbench is
where you would do all of your data analysis and
kind of writing your code so you can write
there in r you can write there in python
you have the rstudio ide as well as vs code and
jupyter so a nice mix of different environments
you can write code in our studio connect is where
you'll publish all your results so that could
be our markdown reports or jupyter notebooks it
could also be you know interactive applications
like shiny or uh dash or flask or streamlit and
python and then lastly our studio package manager
is supporting all of those open source libraries
you can actually store copies of them on premise
or in your cloud behind your firewall wherever
you need them as well as your own internally
developed packages and these are going to be
sent into workbench into connect in this process
so as far as what we're kind of focusing on are
here at our studio we're focused on open source
first in terms of we're really trying to build an
open source model where we give away actually the
vast majority of the software we create so things
like tidy models the tidy verse our markdown
those are open source packages that we're giving
away you know freely available to anyone who wants
to use them the professional products build on
top of those to provide some of the things that
organizations are more interested in so security
scalability you know access control uh as well as
logging and authentication and all that we're also
focused on being code first in terms of we really
believe that to do you know really serious data
science and do you know productive work that code
is going to make you better and then learning even
a little bit of code or learning a lot of code
can help you be a more productive data scientist
and have more control over what you're building
and lastly centralized or even cloud-based so
this means that our products run on a server
whether that's on premise bare metal you know
existing servers you have or in a virtual private
cloud like you might find on say aws with amazon
marketplace or azure or google cloud or the other
providers again we're focused on r and python as
the languages of choice for these and this will
actually have r and python code throughout the
presentation today and then as far as these i've
already talked about them but our studio workbench
our studio connect and rcu package manager all
three of those products make up our studio team
the environment that we're talking about today
so we'll talk about one more slide then
jump into the the live coding section
but really the problem here we're trying to
solve is that there's this chasm or this gap
between what data science teams are doing
and trying to doing and actually impacting
the business and you know creating business
value or affecting decisions in a positive way
so data science teams create things but it's
stuck on their laptop or they're trying to
share something with their boss or their
colleague and they have to email it to each
other or they you know have to put into a shared
drive the person downloads it and moves it over
as far as the other portions you might actually
have automated decisions so you're trying to
actually put your models into say production where
they're interacting with your website or working
with the you know other software that you want to
embed in the process so how do we cross this chasm
and get the data science work that you're doing
into the hands of either live decision makers
or into the automated decisions that people
are doing inside the software so if there's a
data scientist you're either creating insights
or trying to share insights or creating models
that are going to be used downstream and that's
what you're doing today but you're still trying
to get them closer to either decision makers for
automated decisions or actual human interaction
so in our world you'll be creating these
insights or writing code in r and python in
a data science workbench that supports both
languages so log in one time you have your full
environment for r you have your full environment
for python so with rn python you can build amazing
things you can build applications reports apis
you can send you know programmatic emails as
opposed to manual emails there's a lot of
power here in terms of things you can build
once these things are finished you can now
get them onto a deployment server basically a
centralized location where people want to access
the things you're creating they know to go here
they go to this location they log in it's access
controlled it automatically scales up to meet the
user needs all the things you want there and this
will deliver the actual applications uh as well as
you know scheduling emails and other assets or
automations that go to live decision makers or
hosting things like api so plumber in r or flask
or fast api in python which integrate into other
software whether it's you know java or javascript
or your website any other type of things there
and lastly to make sure all
these things work together
the package manager actually eased in this
maintenance and reproducibility of these
environments to manage your packages for both the
workbench in terms of where you're writing code
and you're developing assets in your deployment
server where the kind of production app sets live
so in terms of what this looks like again this
is our studio workbench where you're analyzing
your data our studio package manager which is
supplying the packages to workbench as well as
our studio connect and then all the amazing open
source libraries that you know and want to use
are you know the things you're actually
creating so all that work you've already
done to learn things like jupiter or
streamlit or shiny or a markdown or pins
all these things can be published to connect and
you can work on them inside our studio workbench
all right so let's hop over into the evaluation
again if you did want to do this in the future
immediately after this you can always go
to rstudio.com products team evaluation or
to search for rstudio team evaluation and you'll
be able to access this just give us a little bit
of information and we'll send you the link
to open up your own evaluation environment
so once you actually get an evaluation environment
this is a hosted environment meaning that there
is nothing for you to install for the evaluation
you just go to the url and you get access to the
entire suite of our products for this temporary
environment so you have access to our studio
workbench access to our studio connect and our
studio package manager which make up our studio
team it's got some additional links in terms of if
you need some help or if you want to learn a bit
more about team or you have some questions as well
as access to a built-in mail server so you can
send emails kind of from connector uh through some
of the automations there and see how those work
so really part of the power here is that if you
wanted to evaluate how can i you know advocate for
using these open source tools in my organization
rather than having to download the software
install it and go through kind of this it
process you could actually evaluate it here
in your browser show some of the work you're doing
to your colleagues or to your decision makers
or to your you know stakeholders who own the
budget or your it colleagues and actually
saying here's the things i could be doing can
we move forward and try and make this a reality
something else to note in terms
of once you've gotten to this page
you're going to be logging into everything
with the default password and username
i've changed the username
for this environment because
i don't want anyone to accidentally log into my
environment with with this information so i have
changed this for mine but for you if you were
to open up this environment you could go to say
our studio workbench and it's going to have the
default username and password as our studio and
our studio so easy to remember and log in and you
can use the same credentials inside rstudioconnect
as far as uh the next question will probably
be like okay cool like i actually want to see
this in action so let's open up our studio
workbench i'll accept this and you'll note
that it automatically logs me in because i've
already logged in here if i wanted to it will
come with some you know basic examples of code but
i could always upload or write my own code here
it's a full r studio environment so let's go ahead
and open in our studio session i'm inside rstudio
team now so it might look a little bit different
than your traditional r studio environment
but the core idea is i can open up a new r studio
session by clicking new session we'll say my first
session i want to use our studio and i'll start
that up and it'll send me over into the happy
environment that i know and love r studio the
ide at this point you know maybe i have a script
i want to use i could always bring it in from
version control so if i wanted to clone something
from say like a github repository i could do that
or you can actually upload files from your desktop
so i'll go to my downloads and i have nothing in
here because i cleared it out but i've actually
uploaded a few different things for these examples
so there's some things about pens and some things
about our markdown and python and shiny all
sorts of different assets here that can look at
so if you had code you wanted to upload again
please note that this is not a production
environment in terms of you shouldn't try and use
you know this evaluation as the environment where
you're going to do all of your data science work
today but this is an evaluation of how you could
do some of that work um so you can try it out
here and see if you wanted to move forward with
evaluating it say on premise or actually
moving forward with professional products
um part of the back out here in terms of
obviously we've seen our studio i'll go into a
little bit more in terms of what you can do there
but it's more than just our studio in terms of
i can open up a new session and i can actually
change the editor so if i were a python user i
might be more comfortable and say jupyter lab
or jupiter notebook where i could use the
notebook environment to write python code
and publish those notebooks to connect if i were
writing say applications like streamlink dash or
flask i might be more comfortable in vs code
which is a great editor for python as well as
things like javascript and some other languages
so those are also available to be opened up
through our studio there was a question in the
chat in terms of using additional clusters so
this environment is run in this hosted evaluation
is run in aws in a single environment so it only
has access to that local cluster if you did have
something like an elastic cluster externally
to that something like kubernetes or slurm you
could also launch sessions that are running in
that elastic environment so that is an option uh
if you were running it on premise or in your own
private cloud for the hosted evaluation you are
limited to this local environment or local cluster
so let's start up the jupiter notebook and that
hops us right into jupiter notebook there's a
welcome to jupiter that we can go into that has
some a little ipython notebook that we can open up
and now we're directly into a jupiter notebook and
it's you know pre-filled with some codes you can
play around here you can run the different lines
and create some plots and things but just showing
you that all the different plots and assets
that you're working with work inside our studio
so we've shown our studio we've shown jupiter
notebooks and let's just for fun we'll show a
vs code session as well because i know a lot of
folks that i worked with previously that were
using python really liked vs code so here hopping
in directly into vs code again it's kind of just
vs code as it is you can install some of the
extensions that you want or customize it to how
you see fit and we include a little environment
so let's go to uh we'll open up a file here
open we'll back out so it's mounting my home
directory so if i go to our studio i can move to
this files over here and you can see
the welcome to vs code here on the left
is where you would actually log in to click and
then you could actually access some of the example
code that's included in the hosted evaluation all
right so we've shown our studio we've sewn jupiter
we've shown uh kind of a lot of different things
going on so let's go back to the home page you can
see i still have all these different sessions
open and that's part of the power in terms of
like i've logged in one time my one environment
that i have to log into i've been authenticated
and now i have access to all these different
coding environments where i can do python natively
i can do python natively in jupiter vs code and
i can do all my artwork inside our studio the ide
so let's hop into the ide and we'll go into a few
different projects so we can start off with say
an r markdown that's one of my favorite packages
in r and it's very powerful you can see i've
uploaded a file here that actually hasn't been
expanded so let's go ahead and untar this bundle
so i open up this bundle
file and that will actually
open up these different portions and i have our
markdown as well as a manifest file some data and
the art project i'm working with look over at the
chat real quick i see a couple things coming in
disable certain types of environments where
say jupiter notebooks are already available in
their systems yeah so uh there's a good question
about are all these mandatory you know if you
just wanted to use our studio workbench for our
studio that's more than fine you know say you
have a jupiter hub instance or something else and
that's where you're using jupiter that's great
part of what we're trying to solve here is
having kind of an entire workbench and that's
why it was rebranded from our studio server pro
to our studio workbench is because we're trying
to serve different personas here so not only
are but r and python together for a lot of the
it teams they wanted to manage one environment
as opposed to managing three or four different
custom environments now from an it perspective
this is lower amount of work for them because
they're managing just our studio workbench that
has all the different environments in one place
so as far as these uh you know files so i've
opened up in our markdown files what i'm doing
here so let's go ahead and you know open up the
our markdown it's a pretty traditional one and it
says i've got some packages i need to install
and that's more than fine you can install the
packages you'd like to see in here so let's say
i wanted to install flex dashboard i can install
the flex dashboard package and even though i'm
in this hosted evaluation i can still install
packages as i see fit so let's look at other ones
that are available we have blastula deployer we
can install all these packages if we wanted to so
let's go ahead and do some of that because part of
the benefit of working with package manager inside
here is we get really fast package installations
so let's install just three packages that are
kind of already available we can install them
if you've only been working on your desktop
you might be used to really really fast package
installs because cran provides binary
packages which install very quickly um
so for this for for a linux environment like i'm
running here in our studio workbench packages uh
have to be built ahead of time in terms of that's
what package manager is providing is providing the
linux binary so they install very quickly so i was
able to install those packages while i'm talking
and kind of faster than i'm talking because i'm
using the binaries from our studio package manager
so i've written this our markdown document
it's got a lot of python or sorry a lot of
our deep wire code it's got uh some parameters
and different settings i can do and say i want
to share this with a colleague sure i can take
the r markdown document and i can email it or
i can put in a shared drive or something else and
they could you know render it or open up the html
but for a business user they may not want to
receive it that way like they're like i don't
know what r is i just want to see the final
report and that's what connect is providing
so once you've finalized your report you can
actually take this document and with the blue
publish button up here you can take all the
documents in this directory so there's our
markdown report and email and these returns and
we can create a new asset on our studio connect
so i'll click publish and this
will actually take that document
all the dependencies build everything
and install it on connect for me
so it's basically taken a snapshot of all the
different packages in the environment i'm working
in and it's recreating that environment for me
on our studio connect so now again in the time
it took me to tell you about it i now have a url
that i can share with my colleagues and i can
limit access or grant access based on how
secure i want to be for today's example
let's say that i want to show this to y'all so i
can actually copy this link that i just created
and we can paste it here and you could actually
go to this asset that i just created um
now i open up the sharing settings so it kind of
opens it up inside connect and this is our first
kind of foray into connect we publish something
so it pulls it up here and we can look at it
and it defaults to making it where only i
or the specific user published it can see it
as the publisher i have the ability to change
these sharing settings so maybe i want to make
it available to anyone within my organization
as long as they can log in they can see this
asset or what i just did is actually make it
public so anyone with this url can open it
that's not typical in terms of most of
the time you don't want to make things
fully available to the entire world but maybe
there's some cases where you might want to do that
if i were to limit it to specific users or
groups this is pulling in from my authentication
so i don't have to go around creating groups in
one thing and creating groups in another thing
whatever your it team is using for authentication
can most likely integrate with our studio connect
and then you can use that existing authentication
to bring in the users or groups from there
the other component is this is
a parameterized our markdown
so while it's showing one example for you know
this code it's got you know a nice interactive
graphic and some interactive graphics down here
it also connect can handle those parameters
inside it natively so for your business users
they can come in here and change parameters
and re-run the report so they don't have to go
ask you hey um i saw you generate this report
can you generate a new version for me and then
they wait and then you send them a new one and
you have this back and forth they can actually
answer some of their own questions and generate
a new report or new asset very quickly here so
they can actually rerun and kind of create the
new parameters as they see fit they can either
save that or just view it and look at it or email
it to themselves if they wanted to so i could
send a copy of this to myself or to collaborators
after i've changed some of these parameters so
let's save this as more aggressive and again i
have the ability to make this available for me or
for anyone who accesses this document let's just
say i want to keep it for me and now i have two
different versions of the same report and i can
flip between the default or this one i've saved
as the more aggressive version of this portfolio
something else that's really exciting in terms
of what this can provide is i can schedule this
document because i publish it with the source code
and because connect is a data science platform
it can actually re-execute r and python code so
this our markdown maybe i want to run this every
day so again rather than me having to manually
generate a report manually send an email manually
change parameters i can just have this report
update in place every day at a specific time
so 10 26 am let's not do that i want it to run
really early because i my boss comes in at 6 30
and i want to make sure that it's available for
her so she can see it uh whenever she comes in
first thing in the morning and i wanted to send
an email every time it sends so that she gets the
the kind of quick notes in her email and they
can come to connect to see the details as well
so now i've saved it as a schedule
in terms of this will now be executed
every single day at 5 00 a.m and will execute
all these different things and regenerate
this in place for me so very very powerful i'm
gonna pause again and see uh it looked like a
some good discussion happening in the
chat and kelly it looked like there
was maybe a question that you're pointing
towards me do you mind sending that over
so one i see is that for our studio workbench kind
of going back leaving connect going back to our
studio workbench real quick there's a question
about using multiple versions of r yes one of
the benefits of using rstudio workbench is using
multiple versions of r in the same environment so
while this is using rstudio 4.1 which is you know
kind of one of the latest versions of our studio
maybe i have a project from six months ago or
a year ago that was actually using like r 3.5
and i want to make sure that i can actually you
know go back to that environment and work with it
i still have you know project specific libraries
in terms of because i've moved from r4.1 to r3.5
these packages need to be installed but i can
do that very quickly because again i'm using
package manager to supply the packages to this
environment so i can install these dependencies
our studio workbench tells me hey these are
missing so let's install them really quickly
looking at some of the chat questions while this
installs so it's installing 55 packages it's going
to do that by the time i'm able to read some of
the chat messages so that's pretty exciting um
yeah so another good question was about
you know maybe i want to generate something
that's you know outside of connect like
it's great to have you know html content
but my boss or my colleague wants to see
something in powerpoint or see something in word
so um yeah absolutely so we can actually open
up um let's go back and do a new session while
that's loading because i have my server i
can open up a new session so let's go to
leave the report open up that one and while my
other session is executing like it's doing all
this package installation it's about halfway
done i'm now in a new environment where i can
you know do other things while it's occurring
so as a data scientist i can be more productive
because i have multiple sessions running on a
bigger server and there's more compute available
there's more ram there's more cpu as opposed to
my desktop which is limited to whatever is there
so the question was about maybe using powerpoint
so yes you can generate powerpoint documents with
our markdown this one actually can create one
based off of a template and i can publish that
to our studio connect so let's publish it really
quickly so i'm going to publish that document to
connect so that you know people can go to connect
from their laptop and they can go look at it
and they can access the beautiful html
content that i've created or the our
markdown report i've created but it can also
generate and attach a powerpoint as an email
so this is almost done again very quick to install
things moving across so now i have a pdf report
that's hosted on rco connect it's got some
static graphics and other things and if i
email a copy of it so let's just email this
version to myself it will not only attach the pdf
but it will also attach a powerpoint file so
if we go back to the hosted evaluation i'm in
the home environment here i can scroll
down to webmail and open up that link
and now i'm in uh my inbox here and you can see
i've got a couple different emails but this is the
one that was just sent over and again this is you
know similar information so not only is it able to
embed a gg plot directly in the graphics
inside the body of my email but if you look
at the attachments it's also got a csv file so
in terms of what was the output from my script
it's got that pdf report and then
it's generated this powerpoint file
i can download that and i can open it natively in
powerpoint because it's a powerpoint file and now
i have this kind of branded specific powerpoint
file that i've generated automatically with you
know ggplot with tables with text then i'm able to
generate quickly into powerpoint so if i did need
to meet someone in the spot where they want to
be whether that's microsoft office or if they're
comfortable receiving html as in our markdown
document you can do it multiple different ways
looks like some other questions about bioconductor
so we do support bioconductor packages in our
studio um workbench and in our studio package
manager so you can actually host those
in our studio package manager and install them
inside workbench um the managing of conflicts
would be the same whether you're using r or
studio or studio workbench that's kind of
something native to r not something specific
to uh workbench specifically as far as using
specific package versions so let's say that
we're inside our studio if i install dot packages
and i do d plier it's going to install whatever
is the latest available on crayon or on package
manager so we're at d plier 1.0.7 if i wanted
to have a very specific package version then i
could use something like the rn package that's
uh renv and that actually allows me to set
very specific environments that are recreatable
you don't have to use this this is something
that's optional but this can allow you to not
only install very specific packages but capture
all those packages at a specific version if say
you were collaborating on a more complex document
so we've shown kind of this workflow of writing
our markdown inside our studio publishing it
to our studio connect and then viewing them
on our studio connect as well as scheduling
them and sending emails that's a lot of power
right there and that's honestly a bulk of what
i do and a lot i get value out of is just
automating some of these are markdown tasks
with you know with our studio
connect so take this document
that's doing this complex script re-run
it every day or every week and generate
an output whether that output is like we showed
here a powerpoint file or it could be a csv file
or even fitting a long-running model and saving it
out to like a database or to the model collection
um it can do even more complex things than
that though like we're not just limited to
our markdown documents so let's actually
flip over to say tidy models real quick
another benefit of uh the workbench environment is
that not only do i have like all these different
sessions i can open um but they are larger
than my desktop in terms of my laptop may
have like eight gigabytes of ram and two quarters
my server could have 256 gigabytes of ram uh and
60 cores you know it can go as big as your budget
is in terms of you can make a server much larger
for that example let's say i have a background
tuning script that i'm running so this is some
tidy models code it's uh doing an svm model
and it's doing grid search so it's you know
going across a bunch of resamples going across
a bunch of different parameters and doing uh
this grid tuning so of course i could just run
this and it'll take a few minutes to execute
or within our studio i can actually source
this as a local job or as a launcher job
a local job will execute in the same server
environment that my you know session is running
but as a background a launcher job would launch
in a remote session if you had that attached so
say like a kubernetes environment where it'll
scale up to meet that need and scale back down
let's start it as a local job first so
when i start this up it's going to do
this background tuning and it's going to
spit out some information as it goes along
importantly this is happening in the background so
i can still you know i can still interact with my
console it's not locked up but it's just telling
me hey this background tuning this long running
script i'm running interactively is happening
in the background and i can actually event like
interact with it and say okay you know it's about
it's on bootstrap 5 of 10 and it's going through
all the different models and it's telling me that
this has been executing for 30 seconds so if there
is something shorter running that you just want to
run the background you don't have to publish it to
connect you can run that through our so your
workbench and just run it as a background job
as far as while this is running
there are some good questions about
databases and database connections so if i go to
databases on our studio one of the benefits of
using rco workbench in our city of connect is that
you get access to all of our professional drivers
so this means is that not only can you
use all these different databases like
you know hive impala [ __ ] mysql snowflake
all these great databases in workbench
but also when you publish content r studio connect
they can then also use those database drivers so
you can use them in both places and match your
dev environment to your production environment
so yes the you know you can use database
drivers or connections absolutely
in workbench as well as in connect and you can do
authentication as well if you have like data
level access for certain databases there as well
so a couple things going on let's go ahead
and close uh email this background job is
still running but let's close down a few
of these things that we don't need anymore
close this one and that should
be finishing up in maybe 20 more
seconds so we'll let that run for a
little bit again i'll check the chat
yeah so i think that's the last one so the job
is finished now so if i were to go here it'll
say succeeded at 10 37 a.m that's my local
time and you'll notice that there's nothing
in my environment what i did was actually have it
save the output out as a file so when it was done
i don't have it you know cluttering up my file my
uh environment i actually had saved completely in
the background as well as a graphic that's a big
graphic so let's zoom out a little bit as well as
a graphic looking at the different parameters and
how they all fit so just to show you that not only
can you run it as a background job but your side
effects can be saved so you can save the model out
you can save graphics you can even you know
have an our markdown document in the background
so some of the other folks might be interested
and say okay well we've shown a lot of publishing
like our markdown like what about something
else so again let's go to jupiter real quick
i am far from an expert python developer but i do
dabble in python every now and then just as you
would expect you know i have a jupiter notebook
and i want to get it on to connect and i want to
execute it on connect i have the same blue publish
button so i can publish this to rcu connect
it gives me a similar thing saying do you want
to publish with source code so you can you know
schedule it or rebuild it or you just want to
publish the html content from the notebook itself
i already have a requirements.txt file so
i can publish it and it's already connected
to the rc2connect server on the evaluation so
i can go ahead and publish this i've already
published it so there's this existing one but
let's go ahead and publish it to a new location
um just so we can show the full process so when
i click publish it's going to give me quite a bit
of information here as it goes through and does
a similar process it's installing very specific
versions of the python libraries as well as
using a virtual environment and a specific
version of python so it's basically rebuilding the
entire environment for me on our studio connect
even though it's python it's able to do that as
well so let's go to content here's the document i
just published which again is just a fairly basic
python notebook ipython notebook with matplotlib
some pandas graphics and then a nice seaborn
swirl here and just like i did with our markdown
i could schedule this to execute on a schedule so
again for both r and python i can execute things
as needed and evaluate them whenever i want them
to be evaluated whether that's daily down to the
minute or even as infrequently as a year so all
that's able to be customized with the schedule
so we've shown a little bit about jupiter um
go ahead and close those ones down for vs code
um again some people are like oh yeah i really
love vs code i want to learn more about it other
people may not have used it before it's a
general purpose development environment so
not necessarily specific to data science but can
do things like javascript or java or you know
general web development as well as using something
like python inside of it so if i want to i can uh
open up you know a blank jupiter notebook in terms
of uh there are ipython notebook extensions for
vs code and i can you know run python code
in here if i wanted to import pandas as pd
it's going to run a python kernel
and start the jupyter notebook
so we'll go ahead and use python 3.9 i can
evaluate this chunk or run that and then
i could do you know pd ahead on a document or
something you know i'm actually interacting with
a live uh python kernel now so i can do like one
plus one or whatever and it gives me two so i'm
getting actual output out very quickly by moving
into here now more traditionally uh within a
uh vs code environment um i could actually
go into and edit say like a dash application
or a streamline application so let's open up one
of those and here again as opposed to a chipper
notebook where you're doing you know very specific
cells and text and cells and text to go through
things this is a more traditional dot pi file
which is often more preferred if you're writing
like an application like dash or streamlit which
are similar to shiny applications but in python
so this is just kind of a bare bones example
taken from the streamlined server or uh from
their examples let's go ahead and create a new
terminal and i'll also open up the readme real
quick so the readme has some information about the
getting started as well as some information about
how i could publish this application so number
one you do have to form a connection with the
server so you'll have to generate an api key on
connect and you'll have to connect to that server
publishing streaming applications is done through
the rs connect python package so if i were to do
like rs connect help that will tell me a little
bit about the rs connect package and the different
things it can do and if i wanted to deploy
this application i can quickly copy this over
and i can say i want to publish this you
know streamlight application to connect again
it's going to be very quick so it kind of goes
very quickly because it's using specific packages
and i can open up that application that i just
published on rco connect and we'll let that
load for a second but this is a streamlined
application that we went from vs code to
connect very very quickly and again we can
interact with it and you know get the graphic
to change maybe i want to add canada to
here or something and now i have canada
added to my graphic so again the
ability to do things in rn and python
there's a question in the chat about the video
these videos will remain on youtube forever so
if you do want to view this later or share with a
colleague feel free to do that um in terms of like
cron like scheduling for schedule control right
now it will be done either through the rco connect
api or via the interactive portion here so let's
go back to content for the jupiter notebook here
we approach it as this way where you
have the ability to do it interactively
and you're just setting the time as well as more
more detail here that's a good call in terms of
like crime like scheduling um you know maybe
that's something for kelly to look at in the
future but right now we have this ability
of doing it via the the scheduler portion
the other component in terms of like we've
shown publishing a few different assets both
in r and python as an admin or as an it person
maybe you want to learn about like how this
server is working so you can see i've used up you
know about half of my ram now we've run a pretty
lightweight environment because it's again just
used for some of these evaluations but it tells
me a little bit about you know how much of the
computation is being used both the cpu and the ram
as well as the number of users connections and
other different information about the server
in terms of viewing the scheduled content
you could imagine that as you create new
assets um it's going to tell you what different
things are scheduled so i have a pen example a
this portfolio that we scheduled together on this
video call and then the powerpoint example that we
also publish that's going to be executed every
few hours or every day so you can kind of look
at what's coming up and what things are scheduled
and make sure that they are doing what you expect
in terms of when they're occurring what's the
frequency and you can interact with them very well
as far as storing uh keys and secure things that's
a great call so if i go to a different asset i've
created so a pin so this is our markdown document
that has a very specific beneficial side effect
so within connect i have this
thing that's being executed
and i want to pin the code or pin the data to
a file here on our studio connect so within
the vares pane you see i have a secret called
rstudio connect key which is essentially the api
key that allows me to interact with our studio
connect programmatically this could be something
else this could be database credentials this could
be a username password whatever you want it to be
you could think of it as very similar to like
the r environment that you use interactively
inside our studio workbench so if i were to you
know edit r and vi if i already like use this
edit our environ that's uh kind of similar to
what you would think of it as like you can put
things in here in your r environment and then you
can propagate those into our studio connect and
create this key value pair um for the rcv connect
key i'm using that so i can publish pins so this
document that i have scheduled um generates a nice
table which is great you know it looks at some nfl
data and creates a beautiful table that's great
but the more interesting thing that it's doing is
taking that data and then saving it out as a pin
to rstudio connect a pin is just any file or data
set that you want to store on our studio connect
so again rather than emailing back and forth csvs
or putting them into a shared drive or something
like that you can use the pins package and that
will actually allow you to pull in data sets and
share them amongst files or amongst colleagues
so i can take a pen in this case a small data
frame of this nfl data and my rstudio my our
markdown document that's scheduled will scrape
some data and then publish it to this file and so
this file i can then access and i can read it into
r by using pin read on the specific name so even
though this dataset gets updated very frequently i
can read in the file from the same place each time
if you wanted to do something else you can also
pin files like trained models so let's say that
long model training script that we ran with tidy
models i could actually save that as a rds file
upload it as a pin uh onto rco connect and then
it can be used downstream in other applications
now the last part that i haven't really talked
about that much was package manager we've been you
know alluding to it a little bit throughout but
what package manager is doing is again supplying
our packages and python packages to your
environment in terms of the r packages
themselves like let's say d plier you can
install it directly from cran sure but
package manager is serving a r package binary
in terms of it's pre-compiled and ready to go
so i can install it from package manager it
can be much faster and i don't have to build
it from source which can lead to
avoiding errors or anything else
package manager also allows me to use specific
versions so i can install not only the latest
from 1.0.6 but i can also install an older version
from say 2015 so if i had a legacy project i was
working on and there was some breaking change i
wanted to avoid i can install this old package
um another one so let's say i have um one with a
system dependency let's see about gg point two
i think consistent tendencies no uh kelly if
you can think of one with a system dependency
let's think about that so period color space
what i'm trying to show here
is that it also shows you uh
system dependencies in terms of for your
admins your it admin they're like i don't
know what r is but what do i have to
install to make it work so for specific
packages they might have system prerequisites
that have to be installed in the environment
and you can install those in connect and workbench
so that all the packages work as intended
um so let's say sf let's do the sf package
so simple features is a package for creating
maps and geospatial analysis in r and it has some
it's amazingly powerful but it's kind of attaches
to a few different other system dependencies so
you can see that this one when i go down to these
install system prerequisites it actually provides
a few things that your admin needs to install
but rather than you having to find all these from
scratch and be like oh i think you need to install
g doll and some other stuff your admin can just
go in copy this and then install those globally
for everyone on our studio connect or globally
on our studio workbench so um that would be a
good example of like having one with system
dependencies that you can work with there
so we've kind of gone full circle in terms
of talk about our studio workbench all the
things you can do there are in python
our studio connect and all the things
you can do there in rn python scheduling
hosting shiny applications authentication
connecting databases uh the vares pain
and showing some of the authentication
and credentialing you can do there uh as well
as package manager for hosting your environments
i'm gonna hop real quickly back into here
in terms of talking a bit about some of
the arguments that people have to make
internally when you're working with it
and then i'll stay around for a bit and answer
again any more questions as they come in and chat
so you know you've you know gone into our studio
team evaluation you've created something amazing
you have these analyses or tools that you
want to use and you've gotten things off your
laptop like that's the huge win there's like
getting things into a production environment
sharing it across the organization
or embedding it in your other tools
the other hurdle that we didn't really
mention but because we're solving at
the same time is satisfying it or your
security team and their requirements
so i team security you know they
want to have very specific things
they're like uh i don't know maybe as much
about open source they don't know about r or
python maybe they're linux admins and that's all
they know and that's fine they just want to know
can it integrate with my authentication and the
answer is yes our studio workbench or ceo connect
can integrate with single sign-on so things like
octa as well as things like pam or ldap are more
traditional authentication mechanisms they want
to know that your asset that you've created
scales automatically they don't want to have to
go around you know creating environments for you
and spinning things up and spinning things down
connect actually handles spinning up new sessions
to meet user demand as they visit the server
so it's handling some of the scaling for you
they also want to know like okay well we're
working with sensitive data so i want to be
able to audit all the things that are occur our
studio workbench and connect have auditory and
monitoring of the server resources metrics
as well as user activity so that part can be
mentioned as well and then a few different people
asked about connections to databases in terms of
um i wanted to actually see things from like
postgres or snowflake yes you can connect to those
and have them work on workbench
as well as in our studio connect
so that is what our studio team is providing
the ability to get things off your laptop into
production while maintaining security scalability
best practices with the open source software you
already know and already are using and are in
python and in a single platform that can be run
on premise on bare metal servers or in your
virtual private cloud of choice so like aws
gcp azure etc a very good question came in
in terms of version control and that's a best
practice so i'm actually going to hop back out
of here we're going to go back into workbench
uh or actually let's go into our studio connect
and i'm going to show you one more thing
so someone was saying well i have something on
version control and i don't want to use push
button deployment or i don't want to use terminal
deployment yes i can import directly from git
so i can use an example for today from github
because that's where i have a lot of my code so
let's hop over to our studio or github and we're
going to go full route here so let's just go to
my github will grab one of the repositories the
rcu team demo and if i were to grab the url for
this i've got a few different assets in here i can
paste this into rgo connect and say which branch
i want to use let's use the dev branch because i
haven't pushed it to production yet and then it
says okay this is the asset that you can publish
directly from git so i'll title that git portfolio
dashboard and now i deploy this it's going through
the same process of rebuilding the environment
but um i did all of it through version control
in terms of it actually pulled it in directly
and this is the asset i just created in like
15 seconds directly from version control
and part of the beauty here is that um
because this was published in version control
connect can actually say i'm going to watch that
repository and i'll check for updates periodically
so this is kind of a lightweight version of not
quite continuous integration but semi-continuous
integration if i'll use that term that way and
kelly doesn't get mad at me but the idea that
connect is now looking for that git repository and
saying hey um let me pull in this git repository i
will build it if i see changes or i can force it
to be built when i click update now so i have the
ability to publish with the push button deployment
from rstudio or jupiter i can also publish
from the r console or the terminal and i can also
publish from version control or bring in something
like continuous integration or continuous
deployment if i wanted to go that route as well
i realized that you know i'm trying to answer
a lot of questions as they come in but maybe
you're like hey this was not exactly
what i wanted the exact answers i got
maybe you had very very specific questions
someone mentioned in the chat that you can
actually book direct calls or if you
just want to talk to someone one-on-one
we've got lots of different team members with
similar knowledge to myself who can answer more
direct questions by email or with another call
if you want to dive in a bit deeper on any topic
so hopping back into here again using best
practices things like version control as well
as all the things your id and security team
wants you can build out these very complex
or very simple assets so this one where
you can find at solutions.ourstudio.com
has examples of like you know pulling in code
with our markdown creating these data sets as pins
that serve a published api and plumber and then
pulled into a shiny application all being served
by package manager or doing something similar in
python but now you're using a jupyter notebook and
flask to create your api instead of plumber and
they're being consumed by say an api consumer
or by a platley dashboard so again kind of
full comparison here between r and python
we've got lots of great reviews
in terms of maybe you want to go
read about like what other people think
about it you can go to trustradius.com
and read all these different reviews from
existing customers and the things they like to do
in terms of maybe they're doing a lot of python
dev or maybe their core r studio users or they
use rco connect as their you know professional
publishing platform for all their assets you can
read through the real you know real thoughts of
these people who are actually using the product
and then in terms of like the complexity that
can be built in here again maybe you have other
things i didn't show today like you want to use a
kubernetes cluster yes you can use that with our
studio workbench and scale up jobs and then you
know crush them back down when they're not needed
or you can connect to external databases
whether that's like s3 buckets on amazon
or a data lake running on snowflake you can
also run things like connecting to tableau and
rco connect can actually host tableau compatible
apis so you can actually embed our code and python
code that interacts with tableau and then it can
always do these more traditional things of like
working with different decision makers
so they can work with shiny or dash
or our markdown reports to influence
their decisions in a positive way
in terms of closing and wrapping up here
in terms of who we are at our studio
and what makes us a little bit different again
a lot of the things we're building are actually
free and open source software and we absolutely
want as many people as possible to use that
that's what the tidy verse is that's what our
markdown and shiny and uh tidy models and all the
different you know software that we're creating
and giveaway for free these professional software
kind of build upon some of that and it allows us
to give away a lot of the software that we create
so if you do need things like authentication or
you're trying to use shiny in an organization
and your it team says it's a non-starter unless
we have authentication or scalability that's
where something like our studio connect can come
in and solve that problem specifically for you
specifically in terms of how our funding works
more than 50 of our engineering resources go to
free and open source software so basically half
and more than half of our engineering efforts
go to giving away software that's free our pro
products fund this ongoing effort so that we
can kind of achieve this mission of giving
away and creating free open source software
and additionally we contribute to
organizations like num focus uh to extend
our impact in organizations like python where
we're not necessarily developing as much today
maybe we do some more in the future but where
we want to contribute financially as well
and then lastly something i'm really proud of
is we're a public benefit corporation meaning
that all of our decisions have to be balanced
with the best interests of the community our
customers the internal employees and shareholders
we're not just here to improve stock prices
for some company we're here to actually serve the
community and do the best job that we can at that
in terms of wrapping up as we're getting close to
the top of the hour if you did want to learn more
you can read all about serious data science on
our blog again these slides or i saw a slightly
different version that i'd publish is available at
this link at the bottom that i'll post in the chat
again and that has links to everything i talked
about within the slide deck trust radius reviews
you can book a live meeting or just send an email
to us if you don't want to talk live that's fine
and if you wanted to evaluate our studio team and
do something similar to what i showed you today
you can fill out this form we'll send you
an evaluation evaluation as soon as possible
and then you can do all these cool things in
terms of using the team evaluation to see what
workbench connect and package manager look
like before you have to commit to anything
um so that's really it for today i'll try and
answer a few more questions as they come in but
we are at the top of the hour and i know some
people may have only scheduled out the existing
time but i'll stick around for a few more minutes
so that uh you can answer some more questions
um looks like kelly thank you so much for
answering a lot of the questions as they
came up that was a huge help so thank you
just want to give again kelly o'brien the
product manager for rcu connect many thanks
for her time today um in terms of seeing what
kind of questions you all have as community
members and for helping answer a lot of those
there was a good question about
database information for the
do the database connections need to be
created on rca workbench in connect so
yes because they're environments in terms of
you could create an interactive environment on
our studio workbench so if i were to go into
our studio and go into my report portfolio
i can form a connection here and it'll let me you
know form a connection with all these different
databases but that's interactive in terms of
like i'm basically killing off that connection
whenever i close my session our studio connect is
essentially like a service account where you're
actually interacting with a production code and
so you're going to have to potentially even use
a different login credentials you might use a
service account as opposed to like my account
being thomas mock's account i would actually use
the like rcu connect service account to do that
not required to use a service account but
just saying that they're going to be slightly
different and you would form a similar odbc
connection but in a slightly different way
um
can you close your browser and let your
long-running analysis continue yes you could set
um you know i think there was a meme on twitter i
saw that someone driving around in their car with
a laptop and the screen open if this session was
going to take a long time yes you could run it
as a background job and have the timeout be
long so it'll stay open and these sessions
have controllable timeouts so you can have
some sessions that are forced to die off
very quickly or last a bit longer the other
option and what a lot of customers actually do
is for scripts that run that long it may make
more sense to run them via our studio connect
so again while i can kick off relatively
lightweight jobs here like i'm starting
a local job i'll rerun this because it takes
like two minutes if it takes four or five hours
i could actually build out a workflow around
it and have it be done by our studio connect
so now connect will handle running the entire
execution and then it will generate some type
of output maybe it generates in our markdown
report talking about the model fit or it saves the
model out as a pin or it generates an email with
information about it once it's done so a lot of
different complexity you can build in there beyond
just the lightweight scheduling the new workbench
for the link to the slides again i'll copy this
over this is the link directly to the slides and
i i heard that there was a slight difference
there in terms of the one i showed today
and then for a lot of the different
demo assets those are available here
and a lot of very cool things on solutions.our
studio so one more link for everybody
what was the difference between team standard and
team enterprise so that's a good question in terms
of if i were to go to a studio team standard and
we're you know live opening something up together
so the main difference in between standard
and enterprise is how many servers you need
for smaller teams they can basically you use
one server like i have workbench and connect
and package manager i only need
one server for those products
for larger customers we often
see that they want to have
multiple servers and that's where enterprise is
a better fit because you have as many servers as
you want so you could have like a pre-production
a dev an alpha environment or staging as well as
your production environment or you could do load
balancing across multiple servers or have high
availability so if one server goes down you have
one to flip over to um so really standard is where
a lot of teams start in terms of if they just need
one server for everything that's more than fine
you can also add on individual server components
enterprise is really just like i want to get
as many servers as i want i don't want to think
about server installs i can go that route as well
so we're a few minutes over and um looks like
the questions have slowed down a little bit so
thank you so much for your time today um it was a
pleasure to have this time with you and thanks for
hanging around with me for an hour again this
video will be up on youtube immediately after
i end the call so you'll be able to access it or
re-watch components if i went a little bit quickly
if you have any questions please reach out to our
studio there's a bunch of different links that i
put up in the slide deck where you can access some
of the information i showed today you can create
an evaluation email us book a live call whatever
you want to do we're here to help out and answer
some questions um there was one more question
that came in i definitely want to answer that
uh so our products do come with uh professional
support that's built into the price so if you do
buy one of the products that comes with support
for uh maintenance of the our studios workbench
or studio connector package manager or team
whatever you're purchasing you also get access
to what we call customer success managers that's
where i used to be working before taking on this
role and that's more of like a colleague or a peer
who knows a little bit about data science and can
help you with like r or python related questions
and i'll get you in that direction so again thank
you so much for your time have a great and safe
weekend and we'll see you next time thanks again